chris rock comme à son habitude a fait
une vanne sûr que ça nourrit donc il a
il a animé la cérémonie en faisant une
vanne sur jada pinkett en se moquant en
fait du fait qu'elle soit qu'elles aient
la tête rasée ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que j'adore souffre d'une maladie qui
s'appelle alopécie c'est-à-dire qu'elle
perd ses cheveux et will smith la
extrêmement mal pris et il s'est hissé
levée de seine et la gifle est devant
tout le monde ce n'était pas tout le
monde a cru que c'était un gag mais pas
du tout c'est pas du tout inquiète sur
sepang encore des gens qui lisent je
suis sûr que c'est par guingamp fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en se rejoint
l'ogc nice et christophe il ya déjà un
contentieux qui doit depuis 2000 parce
qu'en fait lors de la 88e cérémonie des
oscars will smith avait boycotté
la cérémonie en disant je ne suis pas
nommé c'est du racisme et caetera et du
coup christophe déjà à la halle à chris
rock à la lors de cet incendie lors de
cette cérémonie il avait charrié avait
charrié sa femme il l'avait extrêmement
mal pris il l'avait aussi charrier à
nombreuses reprises sur le fait que will
et jada smith sont un couple libya
oscillant demande en compte et non ça
c'est quoi cette histoire de couple
libre alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
énormément de rumeurs sur la bisexualité
de will smith tu à hollywood voilà il ya
même la fameuse madame hollywood qui a
peu la madame
tchang voilà celle des chewing gum qui
est qui est un peu l'afrique roquain
d'hollywood qui a dit que voilà il
fréquentait des escorts boys on sait que
sans risque en pardon
score boy des gars dont la compagne pour
plus si affinités donc voilà il ya tout
ça et ça attriste que ce qu'il soit on
avait lavé voilà l'avait taclé sur ça et
du coup ce contentieux fait que will
smith est très énervant il rigole avant
le vois rigoler
vous voulez jada elle n'a pas rigolé la
cccc chat dakic a fait signe à son à son
mari et d'eau qui s'est levé pour
défendre l'honneur de sa de sa femme
jada
non mais c'est fou cette histoire là on
va revoir la vidéo vraiment depuis le
début parce que regarder et après will
smith il a remporté l'escalot star
s'est excusé après vous allez me dire ce
qu'il en est maintenant si vous avez des
infos c'est que vous vous l'auriez fait
pas pour fatou c'est mon héros je
condamne toute violence auxelles là est
la raison merci regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
hu
[Applaudissements]
jun zeng jinguang
hockey alors si
vous pensez que je ne peux pas croire
que c'est pas une mise en scène chez les
gars détails qui posent moi aussi ma
vidéo chris rock il n'est pas du tout
surpris que will smith se dirige vers
lui il se prend une énorme gifle y
réagit à peine n'y a pas de sécurité et
prennent un maintien sur un plateau et
de la sécurité qui arrive will smith
retournant à son siège il limite
souriant je ne peux pas croire ces
paniers en scène et il sait que l'image
a fait le tour du monde pour moi c'est
un est malin et ce monde tout le monde
dit tu me dis que ça fait des années
aussi concrète des cubis son coût à huy
par rapport à tous partout là où ils
smith il a voulu faire une démonstration
testostérone parce que tout le monde
sait que jada le trèfle le trompe à tire
larigot il est vivant et ou pas tu sais
pas c'est quoi cette histoire est que
tous potes à ya eu avec tupac mais il ya
eu aussi il ya eu aussi avec un autre
rappeur de 21 ans - quels qu'ils ont
hébergé et avec elle la trompait et
aussi eu avec marc anthony le père des
enfants de jennifer lopez donc on en
fait est connu dans tout le hollywood
que chadal le trompe sans vergogne et si
vous voulez ça d'ailleurs même les nerfs
à fleur de peau huit mois là et là il a
voulu montrer que c'était lui l'homme de
la maison et que même si elle le trompe
il avait des clowns y est et cgt juste
une démonstration de force excessive oui
bien sûr que c'est ça c'est ça tous les
correspondants nous on est beaucoup
question de ça oui j'en suis sûr il ya
des qu est ce qu on a des correspondants
qui était qu étaient sur place et je
peux vous dire que l'assemblée était
sous pression signe et ils étaient tous
mes 10 et là il avait dit il a fait
comme si de rien n'était mais tout le
monde était tenant du titre et est même
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'acteurs ont pas
compris qu'ils ne soient pas viré de la
cérémonie simple jeu défaut il aurait
désamorcer va peut-être pas peut-être
que c'est pour racolage après t'être
sport européen joue un truc à un film
sur les oscars on sait jamais moi c'est
ce que je me suis peut-être un film sur
les oscars derrière les nîmois
exactement je battrai jusqu'à ce que
vous avez des infos puisque vous venez d
17 algériens massachusetts ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu aux etats unis quand ça
s'est passé eux ils sont en panique de
montrez de diffuser des images un peu ou
violentes ou un thé comme quoi que ce
soit depuis l'histoire de janet jackson
donc quand ça s'est passé aux états unis
ils ont coupé le son on voit où elles
citons be madam farc et de mao fait tout
ça
bouge
ça a été
c'était il y avait plus le son même
l'image a par moments étaient ils ont
mis un c'était nbc qui causaient ils ont
mis un monde où un écran car ici il
coupait mais ce qu'ils savaient pas
voilà comme ça allait dégénérer donc moi
je pense pas que ce soit fait alors ce
qui fait que ce soit pas qui fait qu'on
y croit aussi c'est qu'après où ils
smith a eu l'oscar du meilleur acteur et
il en a profité pour s excuser pour la
soupe fra gas a créé c'est que quand on
exerce le métier que l'on n'exerce il
faut bien pouvoir
supporter les plaisanteries les rumeurs
une les mensonges et puis quand on est
acteur spec pnue il faut pouvoir
gérer le fait que certains ne vous
respecte pas il faut toujours faire
bonne figure à la page
j'ai envie de m'excuser pour ma part la
guider mills à thoune économie
merci j'espère que l'académie m'invitera
à nouveau merci beaucoup
à mon avis à mon avis oui ils sont dues
sans briller avant la cérémonie
clairement jada voulais qu'ils soignent
tu joues à aa chris rock elle avait le
truc de 2016 qui sait qu'il a du coup
face était clair que l on tue les ailes
et ils voulaient qu'elle voulait qu'ils
se sont dit oui oui oui alors la presse
américaine a enquêté évidemment toute la
nuit pour savoir si c'est fait il va
bien sûr si c'était un show il faut
savoir que ça n'a pas été répété la
veille tout est répétée aux oscars vous
n'avez droit aucune un tiot ça n'a pas
été répété il n'y a pas eu de la malle
de will smith de volonté de monter sur
scène pour ça ensuite la police s'en est
mêlé la police a dit ce n'est pas un
fake mais nous n'ouvrons pas d' enquête
sauf sauf si la victime porte plainte à
cette heure-là pour le moment il n'y a
aucune preuve que ce soit un fake ça
paraît vraiment crédible
c'est parfait que c'est sur
c'est comme ça interrogé
aujourd'hui par
là on n'a qu'une idée du losc a pour un
film qui va vous intéresser cassure est
william
et d'ailleurs il a dit à la fin la
réalité dépasse en valeur à l'ascension
je ressemble à ce père fou comme c'est
des williams comme ce qu'on disait de
lui moi l'amour vous fait faire des
choses folles assez sympa il est pas
d'un débat nourri voulait dire un truc
et c'est pas là pour la première fois
qu'on a un événement comme celui-ci avec
une star qui pète les plombs lors d'un
événement particulièrement important on
se rappelle materazzi avec le coup de
boule de zidane fête du cochon il ya une
miss france 2010 ana
c'est vrai je
sache il émule cas rien merci